oh it was a perfect evening princess
stephanie was there as for posh and
beck's you know international
sophisticate magazine gave us five
gwinnetts
it isn't
actually any place or thing in the
universe can be up to 104
perfect
that's how you got beyonce oh
but we've been through a lot as well you
know i haven't been this upset since my
good friend taylor was rudely upstaged
by my other friend kanye who was
defending my best friend beyonce
now you spent a lot of time with eleanor
why do you think that is wow people are
just drawn to me you know one of my
shyest friends i i won't say his name to
preserve his privacy but he found my
presence so comforting that he asked me
to co-host his tv show anderson cooper
360.
anyone up for a little uh icebreaker you
know i once did trust falls with barry
diller and it was the beginning of a
lifelong friendship no you need to stand
up for yourself i'm going to tell you
the same thing that i told mark
zuckerberg right before he ousted
eduardo saverin you are smart you are
capable and the time has come to hit
unfriend
i also told mark to lose the the you
know just facebook that was me
eleanor
everyone hates you we'll fork you too no
this is good now that we know we can
actually do something about it and i am
an expert of mediating conflict like
when my friend's scary sporty passion
baby had an issue with my other friend
archbishop desmond tutu
for now i will hear your arguments for
why fake eleanor shellstrop should stay
in the good place we can do this but we
must remain emotionless i'm talking
kristen stewart on a red carpet level of
emotionless here all right
i know why jason and i were sent here
but
why tahani oh yeah didn't you raise like
a thousand dollars for charity or
whatever yeah 60 billion actually so
oh
but it didn't matter
because my motivations were corrupt
i didn't care about helping the people i
raised the money for
i just wanted to prove my parents wrong
stick it to my sister get fame and
attention
my only real goal was to snog ryan
gosling at the met ball
which i did
a couple of times actually but wait who
else is being tortured are we the only
two i gotta assume jason is as well
giannio you know him as janu but his
real name is jason and he's a dirtbag
from florida what also tahani is a
candidate as far as i'm concerned
yesterday she told me that she was
taylor swift's best friend but taylor
swift wasn't her best friend she sucks
you know believe it or not i actually
found myself in a very similar situation
a few years ago except in that instance
michael was javier bardem and the bad
place was vanessa redgrave's panic room
okay stop talking do not talk again for
a hundred hours janet hi there
janet when i turned 18
i knelt in front of princess grace's
dress mausoleum and i swore to uphold
the host s code i
tahani al-jamil
shall do my level best to make every
event
too much
do we know anything about the people
like is one of them an ex-boyfriend or
that snooty girl from rite aid who is
always silently judging my purchases
it's like yeah chickie a baby ruth and
birth control i see the irony keep us
swiping you don't know any of the
workers okay well then that's easy i
switch tracks kill one person instead of
five but this is hard cause the only
trolley i've ever been on is james
franco's ironic trolley it travels
backwards from his penguin grotto to his
garage of adult tricycles
you've never dated anyone like jason
before i mean i've dallied below my
station i once had a brief fling with a
non-famous hemsworth brother but even
larry hemsworth had more status than
jason should have seen this coming no
one can ever truly turn over a new leaf
sure ben affleck told me he'd matured as
an artist after he directed argo but
then right on schedule it was guess what
tahani i'm gonna be batman
what's his name
who
the dude the super depressing religious
guy the the real buzzkill whose name i
can never remember keebler's car
kyra
cedric oh i love her dear friends are
fine
not important right now
the one time i think someone isn't lying
to me and it bites me in the ash i guess
michael really did flip back to the bad
side oh does one think that roast was
the meanest thing i've ever seen and i
once saw a waiter bring russell pro the
wrong team eric
michael wants us to stay here for some
reason eleanor we have a train a
conductor at a safe destination i'm
going to tell you the same thing i told
pippa middleton right before we went
paragliding in gibraltar
let's go
what what's what i said okay now you're
all gonna need aliases cool i'm gonna be
diana tremaine that was the name of my
fake id in high school her address was
one two three whatever street canada
city canada
arizona bouncers are the best character
work such fun i actually dabbled in a
bit of acting after university although
mostly i just stood around while
baslerman just threw glitter on me i'm
gonna go take a dump you want me to grab
you one no i'm good thanks not even a
little nug nah i might all right
damn you're good at this well hang out
with johnny det long enough and you
become pretty good at lying like no your
whole thing isn't exhausting at all
you know i once shoved a hot dog right
down the throat of the legendary john
wayne
she even named rob's in hell i'm tahani
al-jamil a vainglorious attention seeker
with enough jealousy to power elon
musk's underwater mansion which i've
been to by the way
i have actually
it's remarkable it's remarkable
your honor
please hear our case you frankly
wouldn't believe what we've been through
just to be here today i mean i would
because i just learned everything about
you but
keep
talking i am like obsessed with your
accent we have made so much progress and
all we ask is an audience with you to
prove it is that not your very purpose
to weigh in on matters such as ours to
paraphrase a song written by my
godfather
hey judge
don't make it bad
take a sad group
and make us better
say aluminum aluminium
i love that wow so you saw your parents
in the test
yes
and i immediately fell right back into
my old pattern desperately trying to
impress them and earn their admiration
then i heard this little voice in my
head saying
tahani don't do this the little voice in
your head sounds like the old lady from
downton abbey oh yes sorry maggie smith
is my godmother
hey tahani al-jamil i'm from
international sophisticate magazine mind
if we ask you 582 questions sounds
delightful where are we exactly my
pierretere just off the coast of
barcelona what's one thing people don't
know about you that i was such a tomboy
in high school see
wow looking good okay next question who
would you say is the most famous person
in your phone it's not about who you
know enlightenment comes from within
the dalai lama texted me that
speaking of fun i know this super fun
drinking game we can play every time one
of you says something that the other
can't relate to
you both drink could be fun i once
played a drinking game with ryan
reynolds and blake lively at their
macrobiotic farm with a particularly
robust batch of homemade kombucha do i
have to drink for every word i don't
know up to you just drink
jason
okay there mate
no
i have to watch the jaguars games alone
on my computer at like three in the
morning on mondays it's so annoying
everything here is in the
i don't know how to describe it like
a different zone of time
no that sounds stupid
a different clock land
i'll watch the game with you jason i
enjoy american football i actually dated
a player once but he wasn't my type so i
set him up with my friend gisele
bunchen yeah we got it we always get it
jason i have an idea but it's a little
risky i need you to act as my bodyguard
like my friend kevin costner in that
movie where he was a bodyguard
the bodyguard we're technically supposed
to shut down the bank if anyone from
florida even walks in look all my life
this money has been a weight around my
neck like the heart of the ocean
necklace my friend james cameron once
gave me
poor larry
what
if you love someone
set them free
a good friend and yoga people sting no
last initial told me that
i believe in double trouble why won't
you believe in me
well
i suppose a little entrepreneurial
spirit never hurt anyone you know reach
for the stars as i said to my good
friend elon musk
and then he shot his car in his face
what a weird creep why was my friends
with him ugh maybe we should just go
there are plenty of other people i could
help like my good friend ben affleck and
his crippling addiction to back tattoos
or my other good friend matt damon his
crippling addiction to my friend ben
affleck welcome to pick a pet day we
have hundreds of beautiful animals for
you to choose from and when you do make
your choice your pet will bond to your
soul
forever fabulous i haven't had a pet
since barbra streisand gave me one of
her clone siamese cats and it killed
itself looks like we're inside a diane
von furstenberg pattern
from spring
2013. she'll remember them it's going to
destroy the integrity of the experiment
your honor plus now i have to live next
to a man who once lied and said i wasn't
at diddy's white party
i was there eleanor i was you must
believe me
you two won't be together anymore i
haven't met a more perfect couple since
i set up drake with ruth bader ginsburg
you